good afternoon everyone my name is Ben
Busby and I'm the genomics outreach
coordinator for NCBI in the next five to
seven minutes I'm going to show you four
different ways to get data from the
genome in a bottle project with me
virtually I have the head of the
Education Group at NCBI Peter Cooper as
well as Justin zouk a primary
investigator at NIST who really
spearheads the genome in a bottle
project so without further ado the
genome in a bottle consortium is a
collaboration between NIST FDA NCBI and
a whole bunch of other people including
volunteers to make data on which one can
benchmark bioinformatics as well as
sequencing methodologies look for
regions with questionable variant calls
and also to identify high confidence
variants once again in the next five to
seven minutes I'm going to show you four
ways to get the data and again if you
have any questions please type them into
the question pod so one very quick way
to get the data at NCBI is to go to the
genome in a bottle bio project now if we
were to expand this out we can see a
large abstract of what the genome in a
bottle project is and also there is a
link to the aft to the dedicated FTP
site which I will show you at the end
that has the cutting edge genome in a
bottle data as well as variant calls
done by NIST and some other groups the
genome in a bottle data that is in bio
project in sra currently has 13 bio
samples we can look at bio samples here
we see that some of them are from the
thousand genomes project and there are
other trios from other projects such as
the PGP also we can look at the SRA
experiments a
associated with the genome in a bottle
project we can see a list here they are
filterable on the left side of your
screen using entre filtering and when we
filter we can look at the align datasets
such as the complete genomics data set
for the Ashkenazim son there will be
more aligned datasets coming into the
sra in the next few weeks when we click
on the actual sra run we can see the
reference genome that it was a line to
the coverage and some other information
about the alignment if you're interested
in streaming aligned data without
needing to cash it on your computer from
SRA please check out the webinar we did
on februari 25th also unaligned data as
well as some align data sets can be
investigated using sr a blast we did a
webinar on that tool last November fifth
please feel free to check that out the
other thing we can do with all this data
is investigate the metadata by sending
these projects to the SRA run selector
the SRA run selector is a solar festival
resource where one can look at available
datasets that are in the SRA for many of
the bio samples included in the genome
in a bottle project what I've shown you
here there are many things that wouldn't
confess it on I've shown you just a few
which are faceting by bio symbols as
well as platform here we can see that we
can filter by just alumina and pacbio
for one particular individual we can
grab an accession list from that
filtering and we can use this to loop
over using the SRA toolkit if we wanted
to stream data
particularly specific parts of the
genome or gene lo sai these in my
opinion are very useful for benchmarking
algorithms without downloading and
mapping the entire genome another place
one can get genotype calls from some of
the genome in a bottle data although
this is not necessarily a primary source
of genome in a bottle data is from the
get RM project we have links here
directly to some of the beasts VCF and
bed files produced by the NIST group and
there's also an Associated FTP site
where we see variant calls from a bunch
of different groups the get RM project
also has a browser in which we can look
at specific genes and some of the
variant calls I just like to show you in
the next 20 or 30 seconds some of the
features of this browser so we can see
variant calls done by a number of
different groups as well as a genotype
browser where we can see whether those
variant calls agree there is pretty good
concordance between groups for most
genomic regions the most authoritative
place however to get genome in a bottle
data is from the genome in a bottle data
FTP site if you look at the readme ftp
structure there is an updated outline of
where you can get all of the data sets
including very recently updated data if
you go a little bit farther into the
data one can see data broken out by
specific bio samples and by going into
analysis one can go ahead and get the
genotype calls for some of these
individuals also one can get the latest
data by going into ftp release latest
and one can get calls as well as bed
file
from that location if you'd like to get
involved in the genome in a bottle
project some ways you could help would
be to generate candidate structural
variants from any of the Ashkenazim trio
and compare integrate those calls that
you in or other submit compare and
integrate phasing and also give feedback
as we see some of these high confidence
calls if you're interested in getting
involved you can contact me Ben Busby at
nih gov or justins ook at NIST gov with
that what we'd like to do is open the
floor up to questions so some people are
having trouble accessing the ftp trace
website and i've been asked to restate
it the quickest way to find an accurate
URL for the ftp trace website is to go
to ncbi bio project search for genome in
a bottle find that bio project and then
expand the abstract
so another question from the audience
that I think is more appropriate for
justin is are there any plans for
lifting over to gr CH 38 or a t-38 from
the pusher yes that's a good question
and we've talked about this a lot in
genome in a bottle our plans at this
point are generally to make calls on gr
CH 37 hg19 first but we are working on
methods to make calls on gr CH 38 as
well and hope to have initial sniffing
in Bell calls for gr CH 38 maybe in the
next like four to six months or so
probably and those will probably be
without using the ought sequences that
this at least initially but we are
interested also and methods for using
the aughts another person s what level
of concordance do you generally expect
to see now when looking only at snips
and short in dose yeah so this really
depends a lot on exactly what you're
looking at so if you're looking in the
easier regions of a genome then you
really see very close to a hundred
percent concordance often times as long
as you have good coverage over those
regions but when you start getting to
more difficult regions there's often
pretty high discordant I numbers that
I've often seen or that if you take two
different bioinformatics algorithms or
two different sequencing technologies
you often have somewhere around five to
ten percent disagreement between the two
methods over the whole genome but if you
down select to the easier parts of the
genome then you can really have close to
a hundred percent concordance in a more
straightforward and fun question have
there been any samples deposited from
the x10 Illumina platform I don't think
there have quite yet but I know some
people have been generating these and I
also believe there's an X 10 dataset
from the garbin Institute
that's available for our pilot genome
anyone 2878 I think probably if you
search for driving institute and I think
when 2878 you should find that but maybe
you can like to that afterwards too yeah
and just to make sure they're not
talking about the 10x platform which is
often confusing I think they actually do
mean the x10 Illumina platform but the
10x data we do actually that 10x
genomics recently released data from na
128 78 and the Ashkenazim trio that's
all available on our ftp site all right
well once again if you have any other
questions about things that we've
covered such as bio project or alts
please feel free to check out our
archived webinars subscribe to our
YouTube channel or go ahead and email me
some of these questions or you can email
the questions to webinars at ncbi nlm
nih gov thank you very much everybody
and we will see you soon for other NCBI
webinars
you